welcome to this video playground masozi
integrator no no name and now and let's
see this is kind of a match point to
cross to a thousand four hundred again
would be nice to do that after a little
bit of a slump that I was going through
it's not them not playing you see ya is
connected yeah sometimes it's an issue
you just you start this some water
pairing and then maybe for half a minute
or so you don't get an opponent it's it
happens and then you sort of get some
some different idea like I don't know
grab some some some beverage or go to
the bathroom or something and then well
the game starts and you're away from
your desk so maybe this is what what is
happening to him I can I'll wait form
would say 30-40 seconds if he's not
coming up to this point on oh no is
playing some um let's see starting with
the slide time edge ok let's see we get
the age free line of the king some
Indian de marca gone off variation or
sometimes even called nowadays the crows
ink of variation them nowadays polish GM
is some the main practitioner of this
line is really enjoying a big success
with it 92 is an interesting movement in
test anticipates that he five
does not them miss plays any other piece
queen bee 6 hmm that's interesting it's
attacking d 4 + + b2 came it's a quite
unusual place form for a night in this
position but still Queen B 6 9 a-6 are
not not necessarily great as well okay
so should I play Bishop e3 yeah I guess
I'm pushing the Queen back alright so
the night if I go there should be two
nite f4 hmm yellow Bishop f3 should I
play g3 maybe this is very slow the
ideas that f5 I can take you cannot take
with the pawn g3 is a very slowly okay
maybe you can punish me for that if I'm
able to play a Bishop e2 and he needs to
retreat the night then I'm an excellent
shape but it's not clear that I can
actually manage that now many
possibilities Queenie 8 or some prep
move to to play a 5 i'm not quite sure
what move came this is clear now night
c7 the only real idea of this may be
that to be 50 maybe in the long run play
98 and use it on the Kings solid ok so
he have retreated the smart yeah maybe
b5 now is really on so i will return
with the b3 night this piece has done
its duty and can better be used by by
covering the center
alright so what is this a 5 I have
Bishop g5 and I'm just a piece up or not
ok age 6
oh yeah he's got the age 6 it should be
3f four takes takes him
yeah well I don't mind I'd push the edge
point many interesting opportunities
very interesting position
yeah he was taking f2 and I couldn't
take it six but I have G phone let's
just prepare that and i hope to get a
king so I detect the sound should be
dangerous don't want ur lose any time
here just try to to break open the
position if i take rook takes the rock
is on the C file but his play is
intending to play before ok I must be I
must be really really cookin so let's
just push ok they take on g6 this is the
right one and then look aged form yeah
guess so oops this I forgot I really I
just completely forgot about this ah
what the heck oh no I mean after all
this that's a real shame ok maybe I can
Bishop f5 group g3 actually wins the
Queen
it's not easy yeah this lousy moved I'm
what no really really I have what you go
waves got rook c8 may be here yeah it's
a terrible piece on a4a completely
unnecessary turn of events really
completely I had I was just winning
easily actually I just I have it's
completely useless to give up the piece
I could have just played no moves ok
i spending lots of time it's still a
very a very messy position but of course
on why turn white should win Quincy Phi
EPS of Queen Quincy one Queen before I
don't know he's down on 27 seconds I'm
taking here because i have d6 porn
hanging as well turn he also he always
needs to watch watch the h5 abhishek now
this was hanging he saved it
time warning threatening under 18 on g7
no I don't see a defense really yeah
just the check total mess this game
black forfeits on time he had at the end
of one on time but yeah well around
around here I think white isn't infinite
excellent shape I thought I played it
like a completed yet maybe I move as the
man may I'm just not seeing this right
yeah he says good defensive player I
don't know it was a very complicated
game I am just writing no idea what was
kept going on yeah well a volunteer
thought okay well this must be excellent
for white but yeah as usual the computer
shows the way it wants to play King be
one I didn't want to play that because
of I was afraid of before losing the d5
pawn you know yeah just telling me a
black was winning well in a good-natured
way not like his bitter or something
yeah that's that's sure lycosa certainly
winning at at some point here King be
one I didn't want to do that because of
before but maybe this is I can just take
me for yeah this is what I what I was
was not really recognizing that I can
take him I can take here and this is
this is very strong I i just thought i
was i was thinking about King be one
briefly but I didn't really see that
before
and I was only thinking okay I need to
put the lights on some bad square and
then give up d5 let's say here and this
is just just nonsense for white yam this
now yeah I didn't I didn't see queena
three this is this is the main problem I
could have just taken and after that
he's his wide open the King threatening
this move and white is white is very
very good shape but I over looked
completely Queen f3 and now black shirt
should win I was trying to to muddy the
water but it is it is probably just
winning from black down check yeah this
however is a mate and this really is a
major it's not even materia down he
cannot avoid me tme made in five the
concepts you know a bit a bit of a lucky
bit of a lucky when very complicated
position but the main issue was that I
didn't spot that he for saying so King
be one is very strong in various stages
alright thanks for watching